damit werden hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zum
kochen mit geringem bildungsniveau und
hindernissen mit murat so mein haus
jetzt gerade mit den kindern beim arzt
und dann habe ich mir gedacht wenn die
jungs zusammen erfahren wir jetzt dumm
rumstehen machen wir irgendwas und haben
uns überlegt was machen wir das so
machen heute irgendwas mit hähnchen okay
wir machen heute hähnchen caprese aller
rabiat ra ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
ausgesprochen habe ist ja egal
deswegen fangen wir ganz ganz tolles
menü ein tolles rezept und schon stehe
ich einfach wenn man zum rezept auch
eine geschichte hat und zu diesem rezept
mit mir folgende geschichte ein
und das auch noch mal und zu diesem
rezept fällt mir folgende geschichte ein
ich war mal ausbilder einer partner
gruppe in der türkei im schwarzen meer
im kaukasus passt auch nicht besonders
gut und auch zu diesem rezept gibt es
die geschichte ich war mal ausbilder
einer pfadfindergruppe fangen einfach
ein rezept an ok fangen wir einfach ein
rezept so ganz cool
das rezept war übrigens wenn ich kenne
ich mit dem rad der mann von der sally
und ich unterstütze sie einfach und
macht meine eigenen koch videos so
fangmann tom was brauche ich das rezept
und zwar haben rechts also erst nehmen
wir das ist jetzt mozzarella zeuge hatte
er schon seit seit seit einem monat
abgelaufen aber dass ich noch gut aus
dann haben wir hier zwei frische tomaten
dann haben wir hier dreimal
hähnchenbrust ganz wichtig wenig
gruselig putenbrust dann haben wir hier
in aller arrabiata gewürzt und zwar das
ist da ist was drin das einzige flocken
kern oblau flotten tomaten zwiebeln
basilikum oregano tun
also nix anderes genau vielleicht wird
sie mir möchte ist sagt mir
produktplatzierung nein es ist kein was
haben all das ding soll es gar nicht zum
kaufen dann haben wir hier was ist das
ist oregano genau das oregano das merkt
man natürlich am geschmack und zwar
schmeckt es wie oregano
so haben wir die bastelgruppe ja dann
haben wir hier und olivenöl an
kaltgepresstes olivenöl raab so legen
müsste warum es und warum es kalt
gepresst ich weiß das glas noch kalt ist
also dann haben wir hier natürlich
pfeffer und salz auch nach berlin und
ich habe heute mit schon alles
hingerichtet und dieses mal bin ich
vorbereitet
dh es keinen stress gegen die
kameraführung mit ganz ganz normal seien
nicht beim letzten video damit die
meisten schon herzinfarkt bekommen
deswegen machen sie ganz ganz langsam
ganz lolly eine ganz tolle musik
einspielen hat so ein bisschen beruhigen
die musik geht es okay dann fangen wir
an mit dem messer und einem brett das
ist ein schneidebrett das ist ein messer
meine hände haben sie wahrscheinlich
ganz ganz wichtig ist den wir diese
münchen bewusst machen dass hier drauf
sagt so ist nun mal die hühnchenbrust
einschneiden nicht ganz bis zum bodensee
[Musik]
so hätten sie nur einsteigen sollen ok
schneide jetzt einfach so schön ein
wenig so fein geschnitten was auch jetzt
machen wir's so und immer auch ein
schneiden und sagt einfach ganz einfach
machen ist ja auch wichtig nicht das
finale schwiegereltern groß jetzt habe
das ding eingeschnitten so was machen
wir jetzt was man jetzt können die
tomaten schneiden ist genau die tomaten
und fleisch habe ich mal gehört schon
ein wenig auf dem gleichen brett stimmt
ist ja das stimmt
wo ich es weist aber man nimmt die dinge
hier und machen welche ab nachdem ich
die tomaten abgewaschen habe ist es ganz
ganz wichtig dass man im koch video
gesehen
die stiele weg machen ganz wichtig ist
ich stehe diesen weg gemacht und jetzt
schneidig die tomaten in scheiben und
zwar das ist ein ganz alter koch trägt
unser e book formaten so oder so egal
wie sie ebenso und schneiden tomaten
entscheiden hat sich kein gerät dafür
dafür gibt zwischen geräte kommen doch
ist glaub ich hatte was in der schublade
versteckt was ich geschrieben hast aber
ich bin nicht wehleidig das macht mir
gar nichts aus soll jetzt alles klar
machen
man sagt ja wie beim kartenspiel habe
ihn entscheiden geschnitten dann nämlich
hier die tomate macht ebenfalls äußerst
professionell gewesen das habe ich
gelernt
im fischerdorf im kaukasus wo ich drei
jahre lang meines lebens verbracht habe
und dass tomaten geschnitten ja unter
anderem tomaten und kartoffeln
jetzt nehmen wir die tomaten ich guck
mal ob sie passen nein tomaten sind zu
groß wären die großen sachen gekauft
so ist wenn man nämlich durch das
hinausgehende ziemliche sauerei hier so
seite tomaten umgeschnitten
jetzt sind die tomaten auf die seite und
tupfen das wasser ab dazu nehmen wir ein
küchentuch ganz ruhig bleiben bleibt
ganz ruhig ich habe alles im griff
wir können auch mal zwischen dem
schneiden dass ich das nicht nur die
sauerei sieht so das haben wir hier den
tomaten geschnitten jetzt nehmen wir
diesen mozzarella käse der seit einem
monat abgelaufen nicht das macht die
mozzarella käse aber gar nichts
ein bisschen komisch wie jetzt waren
spaß so jetzt schreiben den tomaten
mozzarella käse mit mozzarella käse
schneiden letzten stücke ich sehe auch
geht ratzfatz bei mir warum soll ich es
kann
[Musik]
natürlich wenn jetzt einige von euch
sagen man steigt normalerweise alles auf
verschiedenen brettern oder mit
verschiedenen messern
ich sage euch aber das ist egal
da passiert nichts mir ist nie was
passiert ihr seht ich bin gesund und
habe noch nie was gehabt
ok also kein problem jetzt haben wir
diese hähnchen hier jetzt haben wir hier
diese diese mozzarella und hier diese
tomaten oder was davon übrig geblieben
ist
so jetzt haben wir hier diese öffnung
gemacht und jetzt nur den käse warte ja
jetzt weiß was ich vergessen habe und
zwar nehmen wir diesen basilikum oregano
neben diesen oregano machen hier das auf
den mozilla drauf und machen jede
tomatenscheiben und stopfen sie hier
rein dann nehmen wir noch mal eine
tomatenscheiben und blatt basilikum und
stoppen dass auch hier ein so es muss
nicht schön aussehen es wird nachher gar
nicht auf so jetzt habe ich das rein
gemacht natürlich ist alles viel
eleganter aus dem fernsehen weil das
geschnitten wird
aber bei mir ist alles natürlich und pur
deswegen ist es so wie es im leben auch
ist wahnsinn oder so dann haben wir hier
das daher das darf natürlich nicht mit
drei machen das ist nicht gesund
obwohl also ich kann sagen ich auch
essen macht aber nix aber ich würde
nicht essen das schmeckt ein bisschen
sandig
[Musik]
also das ist das besondere hier das ist
jetzt bei der zubereitung wirklich nicht
so aus wie es aussehen sollte aber
nachher wirklich wahnsinnig wirklich und
das besondere ist halt dass es ehrlich
ist es sich wirklich aus wenn leute
normal
normale menschen zu hause kochen und
nichts wenn so ein starkoch oder so
einem erlebnis macht so sieht es aus
wenn es waren menschen machen am wahren
leben
berlin wie geht es berlin
ich hätte mich doch mal diese reality
ist daher berlin tag & nacht genau so
sieht es nicht aus die werde nachher
begeistert sein
hier natürlich nicht dass die probieren
aber die jungs
[Musik]
ist einiges übrig geblieben wir machen
jetzt noch mal die drei stück und es
kann nach inzell alleine der heimat für
ihre eltern machen
so jetzt waren wir ganz ganz einfach
folgendes ist kein deo das ist ein
faktor entspreche das ist ein cocos
rapsöl gemischt damit springt sich jetzt
nur ein bisschen die backform jetzt
nämlich diese tollen dinge hier und
macht hier drauf das wird wahnsinnig
jetzt machen wir mal folgendes noch um
zu einer richtig guten geschmack
hinzukriegen machen wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen olivenöl drüber und dann nehme
noch arrabiata gewürz das waren wir noch
darüber
also wie gesagt es nicht diese zwiebel
knoblauch locken und oregano noch mal
richtig toll und das ist eine wirklich
ist aber noch wissen dass das salz fehlt
noch ein bisschen salz drüber so richtig
cool
[Musik]
und natürlich noch ein bisschen pfeffer
am besten mit schwarzem pfeffer und
wirklich frisch mal über da entfalten
sich die aromen besonders welches weiß
dann war ich schon mal die kosten
geschaut und da ist der kuchen nicht
gesagt gehabt dann haben wir nämlich
dass da hier und können das jetzt
richtig coolen backen machen und das
tolle am backofen ist zeigen sich mal
ganz kurz mit jetzt über das hier rein
es gebe hier drauf das ist der backofen
für männer richtig cool
da gehen wir ja auf menü dann machen die
es ist funktion so und dann sagen wir
das ist ja geflügel dann drückt man ja
auch geflügel hier seht ihr schon die
feder
das ist ein hähnchenbrust mal hähnchen
und hier stehe ich hier in brust und
jetzt steht hier ganz umluft grillen 250
grad 25 minuten und einfach nur stadt
sagt und es war perfekt oder und so
kriegt alles hin
so jetzt nur soweit der backofen hat das
perfekt gemacht hat gerade gebiet und
jetzt gehen wir holen das zeug aus dem
backofen raus
[Musik]
wo sie voll aus
einen moment kriegt jetzt gleich hin
hier drauf
so werden jetzt bei einem sternekoch
hätte das ding natürlich das schön
hingerichtet dass es toll aussieht aber
so sieht es natürlich aus das sagt ist
ausgetreten von den ganzen tomaten
mozzarella will jetzt gar nicht schlimm
jetzt klingelt es auch noch das ist
wahrscheinlich der postbote seit 1
mit gleich wieder da so es war nicht der
post wurde es ist der body ein freund
von mir und es ist echt schön dass der
ball die gerade gekommen ist weil jetzt
kann er nicht probieren er weiß gar
nicht was sie erwartet
ich habe gekocht warum soll ich sagen
warum weil ich liebe dich auch ja okay
war die gemeine teller
das problem muss aber ehrlich sein hört
man eigentlich vom mikrofon her partie
wahnsinn oder klasse weil ich dich liebe
kennt das nicht von westernhagen weil
ich dich liebe fällt es so schweer
weiter
ich kann es ja weiter westernhagen ganz
ganz cooler typ den ich über alles was
da jetzt probieren ja muss mit ganz ganz
ehrlich sein wirklich das format das ist
ja mal keine tore es ist ein format das
merkst du gar nicht wirklich paprika
tomaten mozzarella oregano glückliches
hühnchen glücklich du bist wirklich
ehrlich sein mir ist die wirklich
schmeckt dann kannst du dagegen
zumindest stehen keine punkte
nein das hat es gemerkt wahnsinn in weiß
und bei mir bekommst du nur das beste
und wie schmeckt gut
dadurch ist ehrlich jetzt schmeckt
wirklich wahnsinn super gewürz schön
scharf man muss sagen obwohl ich keine
tomaten gerne esse die debatten sind das
meldet die schmeckten tomaten gar nicht
weil das salz und ich habe ich recht
nicht guckt mal ganz gut
superheld also für fünf minuten perfekt
ja sehe ja ich hab da die begeistert
also was ich denn nichts nämlich gerade
verschluckt an war es an der schärfe
ihr seht ich habe den ball begeistert
und ich werde euch auch begeistern
das rezept ist wirklich toll sehr
schnell einfach und schnell und einfach
gemacht und ich hoffe ihr macht es nach
hält mich nicht hätte die anderen
ansonsten scheint beim nächsten mal mit
reinen wenn es heißt kochen auf geringem
bildungsniveau neuer moral macht es
besser
kool savas ist er super nett doch
wirklich gut hätte es gedacht ist auch
überrascht hat die rallye vorbereitet
nein wirklich sie selbst damit ist
gemacht
[Musik]